this program is brought to you by Emory
University well I think since 9/11
America has become more aware of Muslims
Americans have become more aware of
Muslims at the very beginning
immediately after the terror attacks of
9/11 it looked like there was a real
openness toward Islam and people were
asking questions about Islam and how did
this happen where are they coming from
you know how does how does the behavior
of these terrorists relate to real Islam
how can we understand more about the
Muslim community however as time went on
the openness the doors to open this
closed and people stopped asking those
questions and I think a lot of problems
and misconceptions remain below the
surface every occasion of Muslim
terrorism amounts to a confirmation of a
stereotype if you stand back and look at
it objectively and dispassionately sort
of on a statistical level you can see
that the the actual acts of terrorism by
Muslims in the West have been very few
in number certainly they've been as few
as there have been AXI vain' of
christian terrorism you know who speaks
for Islam in the u.s. essentially anyone
who come pypes up speaks for Islam in
the u.s. I mean there's just a there's a
variety of voices and so there's no
single spokesperson or no single point
of view that really defines the
community Islam has its heretics Islam
has its extremists just like
Christianity has its extremists Judaism
has extremist Hinduism has its
extremists I mean they're even Buddhist
extremists and Buddhist terrorists now I
mean and no religious communities free
of that but the more that Muslims are
really heard speaking about their
religion from their own point of view
talking about what are the issues
central to them in their own lives the
more people will realize that Muslims
are people people are people and no
matter where they live in the world what
unites us as human beings is the fact
that we have common fears common desires
common aspirations common likes and
dislikes common love's common hates and
and and again Muslims are not as
different from the rest of us
as some of our political leaders would
like us to think the preceding program
is copyrighted by Emory University